comme vous le savez aujourd'hui on est
dans les écuries de christopher 6 alors
moi je suis passionnée d'équitation j'en
fais depuis que je suis toute petite et
aujourd'hui et va on va essayer de
tenter de savoir comment décrocher une
médaille olympique le parti
[Musique]
alors comment ça s'est passé cette
première séance de saut depuis bas les
jo de tokyo mais moi je suis très
content il a pas oublié comment on
faisait pas vous repasser au dessus des
barres effectivement la dernière fois
qu'il avait sauté un obstacle c'était à
tokyo il a eu une grande pause j'ai pris
le parti de lui faire un vrai break pour
qu'ils récupèrent de cette échéance là
là maintenant les jours commencent à
être comptés avant le début de saison
2022 donc faut s'y remettre et voilà
j'ai pris mon temps parce que c'est un
très bon sauteur il a pas besoin de
sauter beaucoup avant le premier
concours
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
astuces de pros je sais pas est ce que
vous avez des manies est ce que vous
faites des choses régulière un côté
enfin un travail que vous faites tous
les jours est-ce que vous avez des
petites astuces de champion olympique
déjà alors je sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
d'astuces mais je faux travaille
pratiquement tous les jours ils ont un
jour bof par semaine ou là ils n'ont pas
la selle sur le dos ils vont co op
haddock mais sinon on monte dessus 6
jours sur 7 et après on varie beaucoup
le travail par contre ils vont alterner
entre du travail sur le dressage qui
travaillent à l'obstacle des extérieurs
ou non juste aller se balader et puis
après il ya aussi les les préparations
les galops pour la mise en ciel en
souffre la condition et tout ça donc
j'essaye vraiment de varier le plus
possible pour pas que le cheval il soit
blasé par le travail en fait plus on va
varier plus on va varier le travail plus
il va être content de travailler voilà
maintenant vous savez tout pour devenir
champion olympique ou presque parce que
je pense qu'il ya une sacrée dose de
talent à avoir tout de même
[Musique]
où